hello uh middle of the day Wednesday not
our normal time John Luke but we have
something a little early I guess some
people have been streaming it since
yesterday but we're gonna check out evil
within to the side kicker is that you're
deciding to be a boss and try it on
nightmare mode so we'll see how this
goes yeah it's been fine so up the ante
here up the ante so the entire thing is
the nightmare difficulty it says
recommended for people who enjoy the
difficulty of the previous game okay and
you said you tried multiple times to
play through that game in terms of like
giving it its change but you liked this
one a lot more I like it a lot more okay
if you had some issues with the first
one you might actually like this one
okay so you've been playing on survival
prior to today and or prior to this has
been difficult but hasn't been too
challenging so far for me cool so I'm
curious how nightmare I guess on the
side note just because we we have some
evil within to give aways
I believe Shiva had tweeted earlier
about that giveaway so if you're looking
for that follow game spot on Twitter and
then do what it says to do to enter into
a chance to getting it sorry Sam I
didn't actually boost our Mike's all the
way that's okay yeah now I can hear
myself feigning so they opening this
games got a good like 20 minutes so
straight up just like the story cutscene
stuff like that up so we're probably
gonna
she's too much doing this for people who
haven't seen this God it just I imagine
everyone so obviously if you are worried
about spoilers you probably want to get
out of here but we'll be playing roughly
the first hour as you mentioned I think
to me before this we should be able to
get to an open area at some point which
hopefully yeah yeah not spoil tomorrow
and once we get to the open area that'll
be great
cuz that part of the game is just has a
lot of optional stuff that's it's
definitely like the part of this game
I'm also curious like how I'm gonna ask
you once we get to it how much more
difficult it is and how the difficulty
changes I'm curious to like more enemies
more health I've been quite enjoying the
balance so far okay the issue I had with
the first game largely stemmed from the
I thought I have no problems with like
you know survival horror games limited
health like I'm Resident Evil one of my
favorite games um but I thought the
amount of bullets they gave you versus
enemies a three on screen was just not
properly balanced I can get boards of
enemies and you
and they would take so many bolts to
kill it just it felt like it wasn't
balanced right in this game I feel like
spurts are you I'm here dad's here
you weren't here from God yeah you get
scared easily no kind of like uh I used
to get scared a lot not as much anymore
I don't find this game very scary okay
same for me I mean my cousin's
traumatized me when I was a lot younger
forced me to watch horror stuff yeah so
you're like
living a fire
Oh some Metal Gear [ __ ] there's a there
is a Metal Gear Easter Egg in this game
food later we're gonna have an Easter
Egg video up Tango whiskey yeah I got
some references to their uh their studio
nice obviously there's gonna be some
spoilers oh yeah there will be some
spoilers for the opening of the game but
we're not gonna get into like the heavy
heavy stuff this is more just like the
basic premise of the game three years
I've been trying to track you down for
three years and why are you here now
dammit you didn't find me because they
didn't want you to calm down Sebastian
you knew what was gonna happen in that
hospital didn't you what happened at
vegan is in the past you need to forget
it you sound just like that psychologist
that force shoved down my throat but he
didn't have answers you do you're gonna
tell me about Mobius yep sounds about
right I'm here because of this burnt
piece of paper
where did you get this Lily's still
alive sorry I already read some stuff
before I said that in the trailer yeah
we want to find God dang what I come out
of the shadows just to lie to you Lily
is alive and she's with us but she's in
danger we need you to help save her
what so they gave her what have you done
to her very classic horror game like a
little that's fair this is one of those
things where it's like okay it clearly
took his daughter now they can't like do
anything about it so they need daddy
Turner playing on PC Lily needs you
mainly we need you so it's been it's
been handling pretty well for you on the
PC had a crash once but other than that
it's been fine nice rose else ham in
YouTube chat says I've seen the first
two hours on other channels I can tell
you the atmosphere it was scarier than
the first let's see how time ago how
hard memories yes so I don't think the
game is scary like jump stare proper I
heard Alessandra said it's more like the
tension if anything than it is like the
scares they'll do a lot of things
where's your terrible sense of humor
something will happen like this building
like does playing games with
it's a mind games with you in some cool
ways also what's up her with her one at
one glove MJ but we used the knowledge
game to build a new and vastly improved
stem system of course what does this
have to do with my daughter imagine it
millions of minds connect it together
Wesker sorry happiness for one is
happiness for all this mission I like
this resident goal like corporate our
species there's there's some resin evil
parallels to be sure has to be expected
of him yeah we needed to start with a
mind that was pure and clean enough to
support thousands of personalities the
mind of an innocent child
you connected lily to that machine your
daughter is quite special the most
stable core candidate we've ever tested
thanks to her the new stem has been a
smashing success until recently a little
over a week ago
Lily vanished just stop sending signals
then the stem environment began to
collapse we thought it was just a
technical glitch I don't get it easy fix
what the point a team of like they're
like we built this last contact with
them you know what for must be some type
of like not only this it's always some
type of medical thing right like this is
a big medical company that can like
something you make money off the fact
that like you know yeah something like
that or maybe like control their evil or
something they're definitely evil ish
it's your choice it's your choice see my
favorite daughter requires a monster PC
to run it um max settings actually yeah
I have like a 1070 and I had to turn
down some of the shadows to get it to
run at a stable 60 okay with everything
up it would be like kind of fluctuate
between 52 but pretty good but if you
want to do max max we're running it on a
pretty beefy PC the only thing I would
say that's not as a ten seventy terms of
like processing power ram all that stuff
like it's like probably pretty pretty
substantial yeah let's go into the TV
Cohen says dissecting video game plots
never ends well yeah especially in like
these Japanese horror games in
particular like like Silent Hill great
game what you start getting to like the
lore
Silent Hill it falls apart real quick
yeah it's alright yeah you kind of go in
with that understanding a little bit
exactly like you have that mindset with
this game of life and the the grand
platz maybe gonna not be the best but
I'll say they're already doing way
better than the first one
especially because like the first one
sebastian game looks like such a non
predator and he had like show you little
motivation and this one is like this guy
to save his daughter
okay didn't even connect to anything
there or did I don't I'm not gonna he's
deep diving whoa
[Music]
looks a little different
there are guns in this game Frederic
will soon get to that you'll have to
probably kill some some demons and
whatnot on the way some guns guns and
zombies
King Romney says the protagonist looks
like Logan
inception like x-men Logan I guess so I
don't know I don't necessarily all right
yeah if there's a people spoiling the
rest of this I don't know if they're
true or false but please don't do that
damn his wife what to go get it done
later curious about seemed like peace
and settings or anything like that no
yeah we could do that
coley want to see that so if you're
curious we're using a 1070 Catlin
Seaview suite you love that fov suppli
homage it's useful in this one because
it's less like you know the camera from
him which is kind of nice
gives you more field of view but I
originally turned it all the way up I
was like wow this is great I can see so
much but I actually felt like it kind of
detracted from the like claustrophobic
yeah we're nature I'm like oh man I'm
back it's actually kind of went this is
the matrix matrix inception I just
associate the phone with yes alright so
she was just kinda explaining me the
setup here we got to find these dudes
who are the team leaders okay or those
people they sent in or
this is like a kind of his like mental
safe room which is a reconstruction of
his office old detective office I know
there's a cat I want to get cat hey
Scott we actually have the this is the
review copy we're just planning to play
roughly an hour might go over an hour if
the open-world stuff lasts longer than
that it was just easy to write first
hour you'll eventually find these like
photographic slides throughout the game
which will give you a little bit of
backstory and get you some sweet bonus
loot Oh about that bonus loot get you
there you wouldn't have told me about
Lily if your damn machine didn't go on
the fritz I would have spent the rest of
my life mourning her and you wouldn't
have cared prefer Sebastian's waistcoat
from the first game opted a slide
Alessandra was like literally beating it
as I came in trying to now look at the
we were both kind of wondering if from
oh look at that not really in the same
way but like you could get that spider
that weird spider me and like you get
the bandana there's reasons to play it
again pretty much and the cloak back in
the day when they just gave it to you
rather than can you buy it
damn shots fired thank you you think he
looks like Max Payne says bill Kamara
[Music]
alright alright so we got the save here
okay so I need to not save over my my
old slot because that would be very bad
I'm still playing also just so you guys
know the game actually comes out on
Friday at the 13th we're hoping to get
the review up like was it tomorrow yeah
we're not gonna have most nice to see
that it seems like he's towards the end
so here we go again into the looking
glass all right let's get spooked guess
whoo
but first we're gonna watch more story
stuff cutscenes so many kind of scenes
you said it's only the sister said
everything yeah it's a lot of setup at
the beginning afterwards it's much
better it's okay
mom can fix it for you she can fix
anything
so this is the very least Sebastien's of
doing martial arts and suplexes like
Leon Kennedy hey do not talk the bad
about Leon Kennedy was it really
resonable for Leon Kennedy you want to
talk about about resonable six Leon
Kennedy with you you can talk [ __ ] it's
basically a different character re six
Kennedy sucks beautiful life years yeah
why wouldn't I be on what a cheesy line
to say I couldn't tell some dialogues a
little cheesy and I can't tell if it's
intentional or not you make the delivery
oh my god
it's not so a lot of stuff where he's
like very like questioning what's
happening in a way of like oh man did I
imagine that is that in my head or is
that real I'm like dude you're in like a
weird brain pod thing like why are you
questioning this all of it should just
be like I don't know man
and anything goes right right yeah like
he should be various right please he's
done this before
oh [ __ ] curtains come this way
we're like goes like this you have to
kick down every door now if you double
tap it you'll kick it oh it's that
Resident Evil 4 thing wait a second I'm
so scared it says name that I can't read
don't worry we're here all right we're
here we'll be scared with you when I
start us Fernando
what the hell
whoa yeah this does that's kind of cool
and kind of trippy all the same time
team holy crap
it reminds me of that
JLo movie that Jennifer Lopez Mimi were
where she's in the that weird psycho
guy's brain and then the horse thing
that like you see the horse get like all
like damn it what's that really they're
just bringing that up man because she's
in that killers mind yeah that's kind of
cool what kind of trippy all at the same
time I got a look at us wanted you to
mention the black lodge from Twin Peaks
yeah a lot of Twin Peaks some shining
sort of oh ma jizz and the environments
so you can actually do the cell a cell
hooked it up there you got the cell not
a great movie no it's just there's some
weird stuff in that movies but actually
very similar concept actually because
the the first game you were like it
turned out you were in the mind of a
killer
[Music]
there goes our brains guys averaging
reader let's see just get up in there
right in that blood
alright let's just move on
rip stream
and I think so that's just one person
saying hopefully anyways of course
sadistic whoever did this must have
enjoyed it Harv ass
we just started it's been about 20 15 20
minutes this is where we actually get to
start doing some stuff we went through
some of the opening and the the intro
and the cutscene stuff playing on
nightmare mode we'll see how we do here
oh yeah someone's saying you're the best
employee someone tried to block the way
Loki Loki Loki real Loki best thanks
Brad I appreciate it and thanks Nuggets
one for the sell there I had to look it
up it's one of those things where like
you know it's like on you just have to
know or it's gonna bother yesterday I
had to look it up that seems pretty cool
though so if you guys didn't know we are
playing the evil within - this is like
we're gonna play roughly the first hour
give or take and we're playing on
nightmare mode which is at least the
hardest mode you can pick the start
curious if there is a like insane or
like madhouse mode yeah they went that
far that had to be a little harder to do
though
someone's saying uh props to the new guy
directing this yes so the guy who
directed this one I guess directed the
dlcs for the first game which I never
played but apparently we're pretty good
like people really like those DLCs
Mackenzie saying Bethesda's killing it
this month and last dishonored evil
within and Wolfenstein it's true goofy
times they've had a pretty good pretty
good year yeah I can take him I can take
him we're only 20 minutes ish into the
game
so not too far what's up Joe Schmoe
gaming alright back to the curtains it's
definitely some twin peaks' time to get
scared
oh okay
oh so he's the one that gets to take
pictures in slo-mo time oh and this
guy's ruthless so normally in the normal
mode you said that you would have gotten
some notifications it'll give me like a
tutorial that's like here's is okay so
nightmare mode takes into account your
skill or just has you've learned on your
own right maybe or it possible because
I've already played but you learn damn
this guy's talked about a crazy just
60-member
kill people yeah Elmo stuck in frozen in
time
yeah like the vibe of the villain so far
for atmosphere nice yeah about eyeballs
this is one hallway here reminds me of
that one staircase hallway in Resident
Evil 1 people played resonable 1 they
will know the hallway that like this
mannequin head that's the damn mannequin
head foreshadowing that's your head I'm
really curious to see what you your
thoughts on how much more difficult this
is once we start getting into some of
the action there is a upcoming QuickTime
event I could intentionally miss if you
guys want to see some gore I did it the
first time I played no problem just to
see what it would look like
up to the chapo if they don't want to
see it I can try and just play you like
in this guy's manner made it look like
that I like actually blings what if they
didn't yeah it does it does pulse a
little bit that's crazy okay
I thought I was crazy but not so much it
did happen
we're playing on PC yellow flash has to
I like the first one no I wouldn't say I
would say do they catch you up I know
they kind of catch you up or at least I
give you enough rice although it
certainly references the first one
enough that maybe you'd feel like you're
missing a little bit but I think the
most Reber will call this art piece
rebirth that's a lot of arms John Luke
has a lot of arms looks too smooth for
ps4
whoa it's a nice little touch sunset
finally no black bars yeah I didn't hate
the black bars in the first one I think
my issue with it was more the black bars
in combination with how close the camera
was just felt so claustrophobic uh
if you liked the first one Phil it
sounds like you'll probably like the
second one said I like the first one
wasn't great but enjoyed it you might
like this one quite a bit then because I
didn't like the first one as much I
thought the game had a lot of promise
and I wanted to like it but I didn't and
I liked this quite a bit so Phil you
might actually really like this game
awesome
[Music]
so like real life legs but mannequin
heads
oh okay that's even worse that's a lot
of dead people man
oh we got caught
you teleport us somewhere yeah game does
a lot of like messing with you like
moving you around oh [ __ ] he's got our
picture he's a stalker Oh dip so this is
what we expect the review tomorrow oh
hello
a lot of heads now is that arms yeah I
would say the same thing Sebastian I
feel like I've seen this did you do this
at QuakeCon
laughing all right that didn't seem too
bad parts how does she not bust through
that it's just a door there's no way
John like she would have smashed that oh
yeah okay I jumped that dance is
comfortable nice all right didn't get us
though I think I mean I saw the red
that's the lady in the red dress though
oh why you gotta kill the rat for he
didn't do anything
Oh Annie took me could you have avoided
that no I don't remember taking damage
it looks like you just you look scripted
yeah I don't remember well possibly
nightmare mode there I'm sure it's fine
yeah toys sake
yeah okay can break through like a
cement wall but couldn't push down a
myth sorry I shouldn't be trying to be
logical about this oh look the picture
guys there who do you go to
struggle
alright you got a knife now did it we
got out we got a nice we got time to
open it with a door knob yeah we need
some medical sandwich y'all better do
you might help like you so similar okay
so in theory for you you like if if you
recall correctly you wouldn't have
gotten hurt there and then you would
have just had a syringe no you get a
little hurt when he throws that knife
okay so you use the syringe anyways okay
yeah that's just there like tutorial
type we're still kind of in the the
tutorial phase like right now but you
the mechanics games a little later
pretty soon we're gonna get to like word
the game actually opens up and that's
where you said is one of the funnier
parts of it is suppose yeah I like it so
one was it was commenting that they
thought the open world wasn't very good
but I I quite like the open world why
don't I get myself and I think it's kind
of what makes the game really stand out
sack would I'm not sure exactly how long
the campaign is I don't know I've heard
somewhere between years Oh wasn't a
Clayton 15 Baker is dead I think it's
got depend on how much Schiller rose
nothing here are duly meetings better
it's like beacon all over again what the
[ __ ] did you just send me into that's
Barry's herbs heard you like Resident
Evil here's a Barry
do you know the console FPS I don't
Alessandra static skin a little the
frames could kind of drop a little bit
left you to rot like I imagine 30 but I
wouldn't I wouldn't now don't actually
play like you see right it's just a
small town yeah this is 60 yeah yeah if
I take the picture before you guys took
it off yeah you can turn on hurt me like
in game look at how like the game is
running which is nice I like what he
didn't do that no problem yeah I see
like this is the scene where he's like
he knows weird steps up and then he's
like huh that lady didn't hear me I
guess I'll go check that out hey lady
are you okay like come on dude you know
what's up it's okay yeah actually I've
seen us so good in that game god he
doesn't want to eat it
[Music]
Oh broke broke his nose Danis creepy
[Music]
[Applause]
Andrew no what game I would compare the
graphics to but I mean usually I'm
enjoying watching John Luke wait have a
better oh [ __ ]
alright find out nightmare mode first
enemy alright so far pretty pretty the
same yep oh thanks for your green gel yo
kid you okay or did mommy Dan you you
did
the door sounds like good thank you oh
yeah
that is different that is different I do
not want enemy so at least an extra
animate yeah get stomped Oh give me your
green gel
okay so extra enemy already yes don't
follow me
that's cool like that okay yeah I did I
learned that it really is like beacon I
can turn up the volume all the people in
here are turning into creatures does
this evil dead I don't know it does have
some evil bad means the Vice and sorta
just being lost the monsters save it
Kidman leave it to me I'm gonna find her
alright
anything guys ah it's a shiny nice thing
we have seven just say new weird the
back gun only has six bullets it seems
like we've had more than that but I'm
just basing it on looking at the gun
like what Hank gonna actually like
carries six bullets yeah like his the
gun that he started with that he
threatened that other chick with with
Kidman with that was a six bullet kind
of gun right so nice crates nice get
some more bullets all right so you think
it's pretty worthwhile to always break
these crates that we go protip yeah
protip break crates rummage through the
trash cans and knock on the vending
machines tipper
I would assume that the mgs reference is
farther into the game yes a lot further
and it's a pretty subtle one it's just
like a sign but we're gonna have it
we're gonna have over the weekend we're
gonna try and get like a little Easter
Egg there's a bunch of references to
some to the first game one should
bethesda games stuff like that
someone said just like dead space yeah
the the stop is very dead space
get out of there all right guys dead
scientist dude Oh its tummy ain't the
same that's gotta suck for that guy
members like the scientists live then it
has to investigate his whole tactical
team is dead need to get in there and
squeeze that guy for info
so for the people in periscope they've
asked if it's scary or not and as John
Luke had mentioned it's not so much that
it's scared like you're gonna get scared
but it's more scary like tension and
like playing with your mind kind of
stuff and how do you feel the controls
are you're playing on a controller right
now okay controllers fine I haven't
tried on like with keyboard mouse right
yeah also if you guys weren't aware we
were playing on nightmare mode which is
the harder one so so far the key
differences we've seen is in the first
house he's had to kill one extra enemy
and same with this area it was like one
extra enemy farm that green gel from
South is very critical because you can
one hit whereas it looked like it takes
maybe two or three shots in the head so
the funny thing is my name promotes just
resonable even within one difficulty
yeah that's kind of what they implied in
the way the description was it's my
first time playing it on this difficulty
so I can't really say hundred percent
but
but hey man if that's what you want just
played on this difficulty yeah if you
played the first one then you should be
accustomed to this stuff already one of
the key upgrades I got right away with
Jerry upgrade I didn't see you up there
on this playthrough but am I ever one
okay guys that was the very that you're
saying that's number one let's get that
yeah number one was that the other one
is um this upgrade with bottle so you
can easiest balls to distract people but
there's an upgrade to get where if an
enemy grabs you and you have a bottle
you'll automatically use a bottles like
break free for them like I okay so that
is an upgrade it's like yo get that
upgrade cuz that's pretty useful yeah a
lot of people are saying these guys kind
of look like clickers oh he didn't have
any green goo
what is this spam that shove it
[Music]
all right hopefully that'll hold
shoulder still reeling from that knife
throw or from potentially shoving down
the door that was essentially close
quarter combat says he's scared to play
nightmare mode because he hasn't played
evil within since the first game which I
still do it anyways I think so the game
lets you change the difficulty oh so if
you are if you want try nightmare mode
and then you're like oh actually this is
like a little too much for me that's
good always just bump it down okay
that's and then vice versa if you want
to bump it back up okay I feel good okay
I like that doesn't mean you're on my
side you're right pretty useful I don't
work for really downside is usually
better those things out there what they
can do so that's about the coffee we're
about to get the coffee mmm lucky for
you your partner was willing to
sacrifice himself so you could escape
yeah yeah little was it my partner he
was just a member of Union security
detail Wow technically he was his job
real my job is all the hard work nice
dying inside here is above my pay grade
I'm not a soldier
I'm just a technician I know stop shoot
yeah technician suck it do we have two
guns now a soldier would have taken the
safety off
I no wonder he wasn't afraid I told you
we're on the same side let's try this
again
I'm Sebastian Castellanos oh that's a
plan right there yep Liam oh you so
you're not Mobius but they sent you in
here why I'm looking for my trying to
restore the core just like you are yeah
good luck with that I'm done I'm just
gonna hold out here until extraction
they can't extract you not until Lily is
found oh it was Lily look everyone is
stuck in here until the crossbow
mutations off can you help me out if
you're asking me to go out there with
you you can forget about it is a safe
shake so I'm staying safe got me but I
may have a lead on the core I detected
some signals nearby that resonated the
course frequency we were trying to track
them when we got attacked here listen to
this it sounds like a little girl right
that was very the core I think so so far
I'm picking up all sorts of weird
signals I'm a commuter place we got here
no way to know for sure until you track
it to its source
scout after that you were gone you
Nicator pick it up keep coming once
you're out there you'll probably pick up
it wouldn't hurt yeah let's just we know
he's gonna hide we got to do all the
work that way I can tell ya video game
stuff pretty much you talk to him that's
it do anything come on man oh nice okay
so this is part of that open-world this
year it's kind the open-world area it's
this whole like suburb we get to check
wheat and we're gonna do some coffee
stuff and do some coffee stuff cyborgs
man I'm crafting once a game that's
gonna put the fear in him much like PT
what did Alison Road end up getting
canned but then I heard oh it's back and
then it's like oh yeah that sucks that
was by the closest thing to what you
want it there would you say are you set
re seven was scarier than this yeah yeah
there was more like stuff to get jumpy
but let's play the game in VR and that
definitely I had some jumps yeah there
were a couple moments where I jumped
when a dude like charges at you it is
scary okay so is this part of the
crafting yeah so you get crafting
and weapon upgrades so don't have any
weapon parts right now here's the coffee
so you know it's safe stations you got
this coffee here that you can drink and
it'll bring all your health back down
sweet then a little like bar right there
goes down and then you have to wait for
a mount of time for to refill I can't
just abuse takes the edge off so imagine
again I'm not sure what changes yeah
we're still learning what differences
there are this is the first time that
would take longer he's like some parts
okay that's good
take some freebies yeah stupid door
okay all right mirror time who was that
bring back that clear de Lune good stuff
that's part about the first game yeah
I'll sit in the wheelchair sure that's
gonna take me to another that just makes
me think saw oh yeah movies do kind of
do that do that yeah hi would you like
to met up detective Castellanos what a
pleasant surprise
welcome back you again how are you here
I could ask you the same question Fatiha
regardless it's nice to see a familiar
face even if that face has seen far too
much you look tired detective I can help
you get back in shape
but how
just like before right doing upgrades
yeah so upgrade tree so that's what the
gel is for okay so the gels for the
costs are the same
I'm guessing yeah for that sneak and you
want that a prowler that Prowler one's
pretty good the studying hands one's
pretty good that's their bottle breaks
damn 5,000 though gentlemen good one
that ain't cheap
I will save some men all right so you
got low profile and then I'll they have
the locker full of keys from the first
game is back so if you find Pedro of the
world you can come back here and open up
the lockers for some bonus goodies nice
what you want to do
same always be saving dan we Chapter
three ready that's fast also in Chapter
three itself is real long Oh back to the
safe house
that's why I want to go but you want
that weapon part to the right
Claire de Lune is back yeah alright no
one went none of them at the back door
we mentioned I'm diggin it so far though
yeah so you'll find these signals looks
pretty far away but it's the only lead
of God you'll get optional stuffs like
here that's the yeah the road signal
let's go through the game to find like
different signals that you can log on
and then you just choose what you want
to do so yeah
sounds good JM that's not me
although his attire
what's up pelipper how you doing today
don't lie dude
Nathan great that is grizzled as
Sebastian Castellanos just really easy
cuz I don't know i think that fancy
hoity-toity stuffs way too expensive and
it doesn't like it's not like so much
better than i'm like oh okay yeah let's
buy that $4 cup of coffee so what I like
about this area la is you can pretty
much just go over here do that part
you'll do a couple other things and then
you're kind of done with this area
gotcha you can spend a lot of times
they're multiple green like side
missions then yeah there's a ton of like
different sized Shane's just a little
like encounters they'll have you'll just
kind of be like I'm gonna check out the
house and then like some spooky happens
and you're like that was pretty cool
have you found these side missions to be
worth it okay BAM get a key that mission
to be worthwhile absolutely apart from
just like having a cool moment happen
you will typically get like better gear
like so worthwhile okay alright so not
just like kind of thrown in to kind of
add to the game game time it doesn't
feel like busywork it feels very
substantial I highly recommend you
should take your time to explore its
really good for example we can check out
this trick here
what's up Roman from Minnesota I know
you did the right thing do you think of
the camera angles do you mean as far as
like how close the camera is to these
I haven't played enough Andrew I've just
been spectating I've just heard good
things so what I read the game so far
I've been playing for a little bit as
far as like a look at number I'm gonna
turn he was asking for forgiveness
[Music]
the black bars back as an option I
didn't see it waiting for Sona patch
them in no my chemistry says that it's a
little bit more generous with the did
you always have three people that's
halfway so two of those and you did it
takes three bullets huh okay that's
pretty sketch looks like if you got
grabbed twice you would have died fo sho
without healing there's more green gel
in the back but you can get that later
yes and that guy's looks like the Padre
had some fight in them it's all worth
though because we can get this okay and
is this part of the side mission sorry
or was this just a place thing Oh
happens okay a lot of this stuff is just
like they or do you go under thing in a
cool a little bit I like that and I like
that too yeah just like makes it worth
exploring not like there was nothing
like this is you know not part of the
that main side mission but it's not part
of the main mission either it's just
like hey I happen to go on the bench oh
thank you go on this building something
cool happens you move on and I like that
a lot
backhanded okay ooh what's that
weapon part yeah I have a thing for
Chinese there's something there in that
pile of odd get that sneak on baby
little distraction that blue pulse you
can tell me later
oh he's got half a body that seems
pretty normal
gotta go take that to his family they
got it they gotta eat dinner yeah it
makes sense from Makenna Makenna Qi he's
just saying they're like they're getting
like dr. Waymon way more hand axes and
axes and ammo well do they have they
turned on you before
buffa it's just spring right 2018 I
think red things are piling clashes up
here we can take this axe which is like
a one-handed or instant kill yep
basically you can just like check for
like stuff ooh surprise that guy didn't
wake up do do you do you
and we can get us a good Oh a good
weapon I'm all about that
Matthew pace wants to or has asked you
guys getting any less about us vibes
from this mechanically yeah do all the
cyclists have cutscenes um yeah yeah
they're all they feel like you know like
I'm in the event there's a little mini
event they have cutscenes are like cool
kind of scripted moments like they're
they're very well done it doesn't feel
like it's trying to be like an
open-world game versus filling it with
like stuff you know it feels more like
this is a big area filled with a lot of
like kind of cool olive oil scripted
kind of encounter
let me see what credo cest sorry if
we've missed something here
and unless we pretty far back you didn't
ask it again sorry dude audio is too
loud in your silence okay turn it down a
little bit someone else wanted more
audio so it's kind of finding a balance
here right I think I think it was oh you
know what it was I think that's why PC
requirement stuff but I think we kind of
I mean I don't know the exact
requirements but we were saved we got a
1017 here and it can do pretty much max
settings the only thing I have really
turned down was the frame was the
shadows just a touch to get like a
locked 60 I also turned off the motion
blur that wasn't a performance thing
that was just I hate motion blur hmm I
think motion blurs wouldn't mess me up
in Doom and then I turned that off and
then I was okay always turn off motion
oh is that
[Music]
quick stomp ah it that is so quick okay
you have one bullet by the way just a
case it comes down to that ooh
well don't worry a pair more bullets new
powder rifle and looks like some SMU
broken but the rest of it looks okay
give me yo need to find some parts I do
this gets marked on the Massimo do they
have to be find so the will when you get
close to them so so that church
triggered something
mmm the church didn't don't but I like
that better when you get close to
something if you couldn't pull your
radio you'll get like a little signal
and then it'll mark it on your mouth
I prefer that though cuz I yeah cuz then
it's it more of an incentive to just
check everything instead of like knowing
oh there's something here I'll go do it
instead you get to like pop in oh [ __ ]
something's happening is this game worth
buying uh so far for my experience if
you're interested in this game and
you're a fan of this type of game I'd
say yeah it is worth buying especially
cuz I think this game is probably not
gonna do that well sales wise you know
well it's in a tough month there's a lot
of stuff coming out for games in general
never sell as well as other stuff just
by the they're always come a little more
niche mm-hmm I feel like this game isn't
being marketed as much yeah
gets this game some so much needed
attention because I think it does
deserve it
like you are right now exactly okay well
that dude ran by I do not know where
it's herbs here right not sure if it's
worth going to get it though
there was like there's a person here
last time I did this so that's cool then
that it's potentially slightly different
you have three bullets now so that's
enough to you wonder if it's different
because the difficulty or if it's just
different just like just on its own
right okay I like timing or whatever
like when you happen to so not every
building is explorable typically if they
have a light like in front of it or like
through a window that is a good
indicator of that is a building I can go
check out but even then like that just
ran check every building McKenzie says
this game also supports the whole play
your own way thing you can go onto roofs
and snipe from a distance or go up close
and manipulate the AI a bit yeah a lot
of solid stuff coming out this month
where are you Odyssey Assassin's Creed
origins Wolfenstein - obviously this
game Friday
what else do we is there something
earlier this month and I'm forgetting
South Park is that Park this one - hmm
okay South sorry core some division
effect and everything so this is part of
a side mission cool Wow alright all for
themselves weapons -
yeah so it's kind of marking it more
signals not sure if I want to run into
these two sounds like they went rogue
then again weapons are useful okay so I
need to watch and get over there do it
last min do this I got caught and that
was bad cuz three bullets and I had like
four dudes right at me last time
no no nothing to see here
zomb Oh worth good thing he had the axe
hey the rest of them he didn't want the
rest yeah it's perfect
that's what I want oh jeez this looks
for curious you see nothing just belong
out of his line of sight it's fine they
don't notice me yeah sometimes the
enemy's line of sight can be a little
easier to trick
oh what's that guy this is what I'm here
for oh yeah oh yeah one of these in a
while like bone arrow harpoon gun and of
thing yep yeah the crossbows back to the
first game
some said what did the red pulse mean
red pulse meant you're like nearby
[Music]
that's so unlucky okay so if I hit the
water and then you got away okay oh yeah
oh no some bolts oh two for one for one
yeah we'll take it the old two per one
buy one get one free you did it to peace
chicken mmm I will take that
that's weird I could've sworn you made a
syringe at the I'm still good we're so
good got like one harpoon got some
bullets
such a good deal I know it was it was a
great deal there man he had nothing left
after that I really I'm bummed I missed
that opportunity cool
at least you didn't uh at least you
didn't like kind of set it up on a tee
and then with it would've been worse
Oh what was that noise
that means I'm nearby improved framerate
and no black bars already an improvement
from the first that was 84 gesture X no
got a little Molotov - not sure if
there's gonna be mod support fight milk
or if creation club go help her her car
battery is dead oh no what about the guy
with the flaming bottle in his hand come
on come on we didn't upgrade that one
skill for nothing huh Quincy clay says
this is the last of us mixed with
Resident Evil 4 & 7
so I'm careful because the fire he's
gonna drop that it's gonna hurt me oh I
almost died oh wow so it's always okay
so can you get away from him not stealth
from if so if you stealth kill that guy
you always take damage in I think so
that seems kind of mm-hmm ah alright
well that was we're good we're just a
little little bleeding a little bit but
okay we're good we would nice guy like
five bullets now alright let's head back
to the
oh he's just going to town on that body
oh no wonder he has an axe your axe give
me that axe some you are the chasing
still in here yes Matthew pays we had
one earlier scenes Oh found some
crafting some crafting part how
fortunate that rat spazzing out
hello sheep fun boy yeah we need that
gunpowder
nothing nada
so back in and heal up alright and then
I'm gonna go get the shotgun
ooh the shotgun does stuff respawn when
you save no okay cool
well they like story sequences where
areas will be popular with enemies but
okay got that Dark Souls blood-borne you
know yeah alright I think that'd be too
much with the with just like resource
yeah unless like that also repopulated
but I think that would kind of take away
from the game okay so you can actually
craft outside of like a workbench okay
it's cost more materials to do it so so
I just hold off then at that point I try
and hold off and you're still missing
that one part for the for the sniper to
actually Mourning coffee has the same
effect on you or on him as a rob
seems like round getting less weapon
parts yeah well you are playing on
nightmare so was any of that outside
stuff different in nightmare other than
a damage or were they kind of roughly
Eric is your turn to play nope
definitely not wasting anybody's time
doing that why would you want to see a
person that has to learn the controls
that sounds like an awful plan alright
we still on the are you going to get
shotgun right gonna go get that shotgun
I don't that dudes getting up and I'm
not gonna find out
yeah you gotta remember this parts the
open world part like we're not following
that like main story thread right now so
who knows if it if it gets a more
claustrophobic
it has different sections so like some
chapters are open-ended like this one
other chapters are much more like linear
so let's just kind of lay the game like
paces where's the dead baby in the sink
the fetus fetus yeah we're not gonna go
through too much story guys don't worry
thanks Brad see what collectibles are in
the game so find stuff as well tiring
I'll just be asking Charlie what do I do
whoo what's that
well terminal so this brings you to this
like optional working area called the
marrow which is like this armory that
you'll keep going back to over the
course of the game you like unlocking
parts of it I need guns and you want to
do lots of them exactly
if only had that moment it's funny cuz I
was talking with my friends this weekend
about Keanu Reeves and how like I can
only see him as neo and John wick now
like nothing else maybe Point Break but
like any other role is like now he's
John wick and neo to me you know he was
in Constantine too right and then he's
gonna be in this new movie where his
like family dies and he clones them or
whatever that looks kind of crazy no
idea of that even get them it's okay
he'll have John with three and just live
off John wick generally as long as you
keep making them good do that one scene
in the like the train station where
they're just like him in common so good
alright back to this so you're still in
the armory right in the armory right now
so this area these women is are plated I
know they will not die from the stove
will take some damage but you still want
to get that stuff killin because I'm
gonna get that free hit every knife she
got Shiv
[Music]
oh my god I'm guessing she did not take
that many but that many boy is gonna say
that was about five bullets only one or
two to the head yeah oh geez okay so
that was stealth hit plus like five or
six bullets and she didn't die so in the
act
the last ditch yeah oh yeah building Ted
- yeah man okay so nightmare mode
already proving fierce do you think you
can kill another one of those is there
another one oh is that for the sniper
the crossbow you can like convert it we
had to overkill that cyborg man he was
gonna die it was either that I reload to
save how's the enemy variety asking
Matthew pace so far pretty good place
James hey it's camp four of the lobby
streaming game ship wasn't instant kill
him on those ooh I like that little
animation and a nice nice little touch
little mini puzzle yeah
this question is for John how does the
game feel mean controls and glitches
controls feel fine glitches I've had one
crash and I had a bug I won't point
where I pulled at the radio and he's the
radio just wasn't his hand he was just
doing like this I'm not though it's been
it's been fine nice some hot Moebius
suitcases and walkers stuff online is a
shotgun yeah I like the shotgun a lot
nice nice Gani herbs because I need them
clearly not new all right then hopefully
we can get out of here do you feel like
you had more herbs in survival aka
normal or is it just more that you're
taking more damage I'm taking more
damage
oh you have to I could go back to the
way I came
but trading a shock bolt for a shortcut
essentially I do not successfully
stealth them last time so maybe this
time if only I had there's a upgrade you
get where if you're in cover you can I
do like the grab Oh like that's the
trick that's the trap
Matthew facing you still you seem to get
weapon parts in Greenwell way faster in
this game than the first piece yeah I
would say yes feels like it you're
getting a little bit of a faster clip
but hasn't
what was that noise
like turn the other way though Oh do it
hopefully sit in the corner - nope no
not like this oh oh that's a pretty gory
pretty good I didn't get that you never
got that one that was pretty gory I'm
gonna show Lee I haven't died yet okay
so you should have been playing on this
mode all along maybe and record says how
long you guys streaming probably another
like 15 maybe a little less than that
depends on what yeah okay will do we'll
do that to them well do those two get
out of here
out of the army we're gonna do that
other cool move oh that other cool
moment and then we'll wrap it up all
right next time we're gonna go for the
shotgun oh you're just not even gonna
mess around I mean I'll try and stop
well we got to see that other thing you
wanted to show anyway so
legend says enjoyed your lotr segment
Lord of the Rings segment by the way
John Lee oh thank you history of is what
she's talking about
I turned away and you died or if
different dudes they are never mind not
dead miss that didn't miss that time no
ammo oh right the best just fired and
we're we're just trying to mosey on a
hot tip there is there's a corner in red
corner oh man you're gonna waste ammo
juice just cut that thing I kind of
because you're used to that survival
mode
just shoot bullets willy-nilly doesn't
matter I'm guessing you know you're done
probably right yeah normally I'm like
yeah paranoid
this guy's kicking down doors man
there's not afraid all right back to the
first dreamworld a lot of people asked
him last of us or this or are you
getting last of us PLAs I mean there's
like mechanically yeah storying tone
what it's going forward now I mean you
know yeah that's cool that this is the
loading screen I guess it could be worse
I mean it does actually have like a
proper loading screen if you like died
kind of thing
what
geez just gonna do that all night she
moves to get that axe oh that's you Oh
[Music]
tension it's melting rip - that was kind
of yes though you're like right away you
even had the prompt the prompt even came
up that was unfortunate
all right try again damn so this is
already a lot harder than your first
playthrough
or the other chick shows up Oh Oh a
different person all right lady we know
you go away JH come on make sure I'm
definitely know around look at you not
even afraid there's an accident yeah
where's your buddy he's dead
[Music]
hey tipper be be mindful don't be don't
be like don't be that kind of guy
alright Joe Schmoe games and enjoyed
enjoyed watching you guys help me decide
to get this game oh she's got a face on
her back what is that you see Charlie
that is yeah all right
don't forget the axe that's over there
oh yeah where is this cool thing you
want to show off alright who an herb I
didn't hear that it's just a beauty mark
oh yeah I guess just beating work that
just happens to be in the shape of his
face I guess yeah I'm not shocked if
someone posted the ending they weren't
supposed to but let me go get the ending
from this is not the kind of game where
I'm like yo I just want to see the
ending that's one of the is that one of
those ladies yeah I'll call her the
witch yesterday it's like everyone the
first time you play don't don't wake her
up
why what's gonna happen okay plan so
planned she's still alive bro damn
are you serious
Jesus six bullets and an axe for that
lady and her tentacles are still moving
damn nightmare mode ain't no joke
ooh a little pouch of I find these again
why do you want to explore okay so is
that it no okay I was like that you said
the house man you have is like 13 okay
oh she dead oh thanks
that's not good Sam one cool thing you
knew if you hold your gun out it's the
gun out nice I'm guessing you need to
worry about that later on
lol left for dead which it's close man
she was hard as balls to kill him left
for dead it's freezing did you get
teleported so far man it's the lady
isn't it in the bathroom calling the
lady
nope it's Jean Grey oh it's a trailer
one sweet Oh milady
okay
and this is not part of the story this
is optional you could this is all
alright this is the first time I'm a
little creeped out I gotta get out of
here no [ __ ] it's coming for you I like
how she's got the quick walk up but then
she's also slow as hell
I like that humming too
oh you gotta get the ami in there
oh she's a theory all she can walk
through doors lady was saying so that's
got a keycard over there great we got
follower
update their universe
there's got to be some way to get out of
here
josepho if I won't be doing more evil
within
not livestream guys okay that's us what
the hell is on your pictures there oh
yeah yeah this might get me out of here
but
it's nightmare mode man we got the card
now let us out come on come on minute
okay we're out
did I just imagine that no that was damn
what was that thing was that real or all
in my mind again your in your in your
own minds like it it already something
on the that a shelf I don't know whose
some Hughes action look like pills run
man run damn that's that's just a little
side a little side thing that's the
thing you completely skip mmm that's
pretty freakin cool man totally and
actually an awful encounter but once you
have seen her the first time she will
randomly appear out in the open world
for like a no no effing way and it'll
get all that cold and you have to like
run away from her oh [ __ ] dude that was
the first time this whole playthrough I
felt a little nervous I was nervous
there like I thought of the end yeah
there's a safe room right over there so
let's just get let's just get to that
yeah that was a cool one to end on I
like that was a yeah so I wanted to do
it oh no I need a shock bolt get in on
the go let's see the bolts actually do
not know how to crack on the go
I'm time go through the front door can
you even go through the front door know
how you crapped on the go
you're supposed to be able to do it I've
just never done before we're about to
stop Robert Hannah Larry did you not see
the lady that just chased us that alone
was worth it
yeah that's a good place to call
actually I take it back
when one needs a shock bolt so the game
gives me a shock for everyone
maybe that's one of their ways of
telling you like oh by the way
and Mobius dude ain't messing around -
that was like five bullets wait he's
Mobius right yep tune their I want to
see Rob play this with his commentary
skirt and him screaming like a girl
alright well that was uh no like about
an hour fifteen ish maybe a little hour
thirty be played uh it claims we played
for about an hour forty or forty minutes
okay but you know that was a nightmare
mode if you guys were curious and it
seems a little bit more difficult they
had it added an enemy in like a certain
locations and then that I don't know I
called her the witch from left for dead
but that enemy type seemed to be a lot
more yeah it took a lot more bullets I
think it was like he stabbed it with the
axe and he shot her like five times or
something like that which is kind of a
lot for like any enemy type so if you're
thinking about playing nightmare mode
that's nightmare mode if not play on
survival obviously which seems a little
bit more for everybody I guess
and thanks family for playing of course
any last thoughts for you of before we
kind of head out here in terms of your
thoughts on evil within two and games
awesome this you guys like what you saw
her I said go get it
alright yes stay tuned for more GameSpot
content on the evil within - I think
we're hoping for the review tomorrow
from Alessandro so stay tuned for that
and stay tuned for more live streams we
normally livestream at 11:00 a.m. the
last few days we've been doing some back
to backs just because there's been a lot
going on this week but until next time
guys thank you guys all for tuning in
don't forget to hit that sub and fall
button we appreciate it have a good rest
of your is Wednesday right packetize
have a good Wednesday see you guys bye
bye
[Music]
you